One of the worst places in the world to be
right now from the standpoint of corona virus
is the U.S. state of Florida.
In total, the United States is one of the
worst places to be like if you look at just
country level data.
But thankfully for now, some states in the
United States are actually doing pretty well.
But if you look in more detail at the state
by state data, there are some spots in the
United States that are the worst places to
be, and that includes Arizona, that includes
Texas, that includes California.
But certainly Florida is one of those places.
Florida has 21 million people.
That's more than many countries have.
If Florida were a country, it would be one
of the countries with the worst outbreaks
in the world right now in terms of the growth
rate of cases.
Florida Republican state Rep. Anthony Sabattini
went on CNN said Florida is doing just fine.
Now, I'm gonna play some clips for you.
He sounds completely delusional.
He praised Governor Ron DeSantis, his handling
of the virus.
Ron DeSantis, the Florida Republican governor,
is engaged in a battle with Georgia Governor
Kemp and Texas Governor Greg Abbott for who
has had the absolutely worst response.
The outbreak in Miami is being compared to
the initial outbreak in Wuhan, China.
Dr. An ABO said, quote, Miami is now the epicenter
of the pandemic.
What we were seeing in, Ruthanne, six months
ago, five months ago, now we are there.
But Anthony, Sabattini doesn't care.
Here he is, by the way, Sabattini.
I feel like he's doing a disservice to the
Sabattini name.
Great Argentinian tennis player Gabby, Sabattini
and Anthony.
Sabattini shows up on CNN and tries to tell
Brianna Keilar that everything's fine in Florida.
Brianna Keilar tries to bring him back to
reality.
Well, Brianna, I think what you're doing is
what a lot of folks in the middle of Don,
which is HARP takes exclusively on one metric,
namely the cases, cases.
Cases, cases.
The media is almost exclusively focused on
this one.
No.
Versus the two most important numbers.
Obviously, hospitalizations and fatalities
were in most parts of the states, flatlined
or gone down, especially in mine.
So for now, Sabattini is just pushing the
talking point.
Cases don't really matter.
What matters is hospitalizations.
What matters is deaths.
But remember, the cases are the earliest indicator.
First you test positive, then you get sick
enough to have to go to the hospital.
Then some portion of those folks who go to
the hospital die.
And case in point, cases have been exploding
in Florida since around June 26.
That's like 20 days ago.
Deaths started to spike a few days ago.
Yesterday, again, Florida said a new single
day death record and then they did it again.
I mean, multiple new single day death records
in Florida.
So deaths are spiking.
Anthony Sabattini is pretending that they're
not.
But let's continue with the interview and
you're going to hear the state of the state
rep from Florida say Florida is doing fine
and disarm.
This is doing great.
And so if we focus on the two more relevant
metrics, Florida's doing just fine.
OK.
We focus on case positivity.
And we just did a report on the metrics that
you cited.
Perhaps you didn't hear it, but you've had
actually in Leon County circuit judge who
said and look, we checked representative.
We checked with constitutional experts who
said and this is what the court judge said,
and this is this is what the circuit judge
said.
And constitutional experts agree with this,
the ordinance, because you lost in Leon County,
the ordinance has a, quote, valid basis to
protect public health because, I mean, you
talk about this being an extraordinary circumstance,
but we are in an extraordinary circumstance.
We're in a pandemic.
And Florida is not doing just fine.
No, they are.
But on the judge issue, there's about hundred
circuit.
You are Giono, you state of Florida is doing.
You think Florida is doing fine right now?
Absolutely.
I think the governor's response has been on
point.
I think that you the metrics that matter the
most.
We're doing very well.
And if you're counting cases, you're going
to scare people.
But what they don't realize this case is death
far less.
Four thousand five hundred twenty one total
cases.
Three hundred 1000 last week in Florida.
Utilizations increasing.
Nineteen thousand three hundred thirty four
fifty four hospital ICU use have reached capacity
in Florida.
Another 40 hospitals show that ICU use are
at 10 percent or less availability.
Let me remind you, you say you're doing issues
where the where the nation's third largest
state.
So out of the 70 thousand new cases we had
last week, we had about one hundred more people
go to hospital.
That is a extremely small number when you're
looking at the fact that we have twenty one
and a half million people, certainly not the
sort of numbers that would drive people to
shut down the economy near the epicenter of
a global pandemic.
And you can't even admit that that's actually
a false assessment entirely.
I don't even know what you mean by epicenter.
Notice that this is not.
About math.
We like to think sometimes on the left naively,
that if we just show them the numbers, everybody
is going to get on the same page.
Everybody will understand what's going on.
Everybody will agree.
Just show them the numbers.
But it doesn't work.
And yesterday, we spoke to Dr. Christopher
DiCarlo about critical thinking and about
data and statistics.
And it just doesn't work that way.
And part of the reason it doesn't work that
way is you have people like Anthony, Sabattini
and Donald Trump just saying things that aren't
based, in fact, going around saying Florida's
fine.
We're not the epicenter.
There's nothing to see here.
Reality doesn't matter.
Now, on top of this, we also have to remember
we have much reason to think that we aren't
even really getting the true numbers out of
Florida.
We go back about a month, six weeks.
There were already allegations that Florida
was covering up or misreporting data.
Now, officially, as of two days ago, the Trump
administration says stop reporting to the
CDC.
Instead, report your data to HHS and Alex
Azar Trump tool Alex Azar, who at one point
hired a labradoodle breeder to deal with the
day to day of corona virus.
That was early on.
So even with the numbers we're getting out
of Florida.
Florida's deaths have hit new single day records
multiple times in the last week.
The last week in total has been the worst
week for Florida in terms of cases, in terms
of deaths.
But remember that on the tail end of this,
the real data might be even worse.
Florida is the epicenter of the global pandemic
at this point in time.
And part of the reason why is they insist
everything's completely fine.
It's like the naked gun scene with the great
comedic actor Leslie Nielsen, where he's saying,
please disperse.
Nothing to see here.
Please disperse.
And a building is exploding in the background.
Many of you know the scene.
It's been the subject of a lot of meaning
on the Internet.
That's essentially what Anthony Sabattini
is doing here.
And it's absolutely insane.
Absolutely and utterly insane.